Jacques est tombé dans la marmite depuis
tout petit passionné des chemins de fer
il a intégré les passionnés du train une
association de modélisme ferroviaire ça
permet d'aborder tout un tas de
techniques différentes la
menuiserie le décor l'électricité
l'électronique quelques mètres plus loin
c'est une histoire similaire que raconte
rwan ce passionné a commencé à
construire son bateau à l'âge de 15 ans
un bateau qui a nécessité plus de 500
heures de travail Erwan a réussi à
transmettre sa passion à son fils ah
j'ai mon fils qui est qui est derrière
moi et enfin qui est dans dans qui
s'occupe de l'écollage pour les petits
avec son bateau on l'avait construit
ensemble quand il avait 4 5 ans il a
fait un autre voilier entre 7 et 8 ans
et maintenant il donne des des conseils
aux petits jeunes pendant les expos du
côté de fontener lefleur c'est
l'aviation qui fait rêver l'association
modélisme et loisirs technique promeut
le modélisme aérien quand on a les
jeunes c'est aussi voilà on part au
début de quelque chose qui fait rêver un
avion qui vole puis ensuite on va plus
dans le détail avec eux de pourquoi ça
vole comment on le construit et comment
voilà on on les a on les accompagne pour
voilà pour que éventuellement ça puisse
devenir une passion la passion dépasser
les simples exposants à Montini le
Bretonneux plus de 5000 visiteurs sont
venus admirer les modèles en 2024 le
club de fontené le fleurri organisera
les championnats de France